si aujourd'hui la majorité des jeunes
foyers h leurs épices dans le petit
hachoir électrique
beaucoup de familles restent encore dans
la tradition et préparent leurs épices
dans des pilons et ce n'est pas
seulement par habitude ou par nostalgie
beaucoup vous diront qu un rougail
préparé dans un pilon aura toujours
meilleur goût que celui fait dans un
choix
réduire saint-etienne dans le sud de
l'île le soleil vient juste de se lever
pourtant leur est déjà bien avancé pour
ans doit deux fois par semaine le saint
louisiens 6-1 et rivière à la recherche
de sa matière première
il est tailleur de pierre fabricant de
piles aux oscar avoue trouver à vous
reconnaître le fil face à cela il ya est
difficile et on le reçoit ressent
fonnier gros matin va voir le soleil
tape frappé le rocher et l'euro c'est
tout l'appareil ressemble ça nous
rassure moi c'est pas bon la lumière du
soleil rond plus compliqué la recherche
d'antoine car si la nuit tous les chats
sont gris dit-on au soleil toutes les
paires aussi son gré or à tout ne sont
utilisables pour fabriquer un pilon mais
comme il le dit travailler la pierre est
un métier de patience pour se rendre au
chalet en patience et à ses séides un
rocher durant l'invasion par les ronces
et en breton
une fois lapierre sélectionnés antoine
repart chez lui son sac sur l'épaule
là commence un long travail de façonnage
essentiellement au marteau et au ciseau
c'est à l'âge de 12 ans quand on a
commencé à tailler la pierre un métier
physique n'est pas difficile il suffit
juste de s'habituer
comment s'adapter à des pillages et aux
autres c'est mon père ou grand-père
monde à moi je fais des pilots les plots
des moulins à maïs et cendrier habana
des faits sa pitance
c'était un métier longtemps dessin gomez
en et traditions qui ne prend pas de
suicide
3 quai des arts à pissila furent pour
fabriquer un pilon antoine prendra une
journée entière à bouffer loin pour sa
valeureuse et à al harir rejoint qu'on
reçoit maintenant mas souffre parfois
d'un rose peut gagner des débits d'eau
ou bien 3 kg et dépend parfois un pilon
fini fait si parfois pilon le raid rep
est cassé ou bien ou pour effet si
l'europe attendait ou des voisins avant
c'était plus un mot à dire
il existe aujourd'hui pas plus de 3
tailleur de pilon à la main sur l'île de
la réunion et ce sont déjà des anciens
la demande n'étant plus importante
qu'avant peu de jeunes se tournent vers
ce métier où il a remis un mot ici en
détail at t est rouverte et roumains
comme des savanes où rapid aller et
difficile selon l'ogbl habile au pareil
dans un foyer achète un python c'est en
général pour toute une vie
même si les hachoirs sont de plus en
plus présents dans les ménages
peu de chance que ce dernier supplante
le pilon pour les amateurs de cuisine
traditionnelle la raison est toute
simple c'est le goûter